[Applause]
well it's been a very fun and engaging
first day of the faculty summit it's
been great enjoying this year's theme
titled future of work but all the
subtitles that go along with that and of
course like all of our faculty submits
we take a theme and we also hang many
different topics on it including ones
that might not seem exactly aligned with
the future of work like we've done
interesting briefings on machine
learning human-computer interaction the
intersection of AI and HCI and so on but
the future of work brings together such
a rich intersection of topics AI HCI
psychology human factors social systems
economics fabulous and beyond the the
topics and the content I personally have
had a blast catching up with so many of
you so many colleagues including long
term friends former students who are now
upstanding colleagues and professors and
universities former interns and folks
who I've wanted to get to know better
over time I was really impressed to hear
this year we have about 250 faculty from
almost every continent representing 125
universities fabulous to have you all
here with us today and of course people
joining from Microsoft Research
I'd like to cap off this this wonderful
day with a discussion with a man I
admire greatly and with whom have had a
chance to to work with now surprising to
me sometimes over decades during my time
at Microsoft please welcome Bill Gates
co-chair of the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation bill
so it's great to have you here I love
hearing about your your top of mind
which is I guess always Microsoft some
extent but Gates Foundation and work
you're doing with Melinda and on these
high payoff opportunities for making the
world a better place I know you think
really deeply about where you can have
the most impact and to hear what's
happening our foundation has two big
areas focus the first is our global work
where we go to the developing countries
and starting with Health try to improve
the conditions there and the second is
working on education primarily focused
here in the United States and in the
first area
you know we're driven by the fact that
there's still a big part of the world
where over 10% of kids die before the
age of five when we got started that was
the global average now due to some
things we and our partners have done
it's been cut in half and so you know we
have less less than five million kids
die before the age of five every year
that's still a lot you know the three
big causes are still malaria diarrhea
pneumonia but we've gotten some great
vaccines out I spent all day yesterday
on the birthing process and how we make
that safer for both the mother and the
child
so our global health work really has
gone beyond our expectation in what's
been achieved it's partly biology has
gotten better there were some really
powerful things that had been ignored
that needed to be done and it's also the
case that issue is you get rid of any
health problem the child is better off
that is they're closer to their growth
curve their immune system is better and
so you always see a nonlinear effect
when you get rid of something that kids
10% to the kids
attributed you'll reduce about 15
percent of the deaths because whatever
priming that disease did to weaken the
child to make them more susceptible to
dying of the other disease you're
getting rid of that as well and so now
big thing for us is nutrition keeping
kids on their growth path where we've
had to fund all this microbiome work but
it looks extremely promising
to have dramatic reductions in
malnutrition which will have benefits
both for death reduction and for the
mental and physical capacity of the
survivors our education work in some
ways has been less dramatic in that
although there's some amazing new
curriculum things some teacher feedback
things Student Survey things thing
called the Common Core which organized
the math curriculum in a much far more
logical rigorous way the actual
achievement in terms of reducing
dropouts in high school
reducing dropouts in college the you
know even though the u.s. puts more
money into this per student than any
country in the world by quite a bit both
on a relative and absolute basis law on
an absolute basis were about the same as
we're 20 years ago on a relative basis
were were weaker I still believe that
it's a solvable problem part of it is a
technology tools opportunity thing maybe
30% 70% you have to create a framework
where the measurement of excellence is
agreed to and so you're in a continuous
improvement process so beyond being
co-founder of Microsoft and the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation we all view you
as the co-founder of Microsoft Research
and what are your thoughts about the
contribution is that crazy idea back in
1991 have led to in the world and on
technology the company itself society
more broadly with over almost 30 years
old MSR
well it was phenomenal that we actually
you know and when we did our Lea
software products we thought wow we've
got money left over we can do some
long-term things and you know we were
students of Xerox PARC partly because we
were beneficiaries in terms of the crop
to user interface of amazing work that
people like Butler Lampson Alan Kay
Charles Simoni and of course we hired
Charles so we got kind of a direct cut
Becker was help
yeah it's shock amazing what they did
was amazing now the company they were
part of didn't get profitability from it
but it was still a great great set of
contributions so even early on we
started to do something after language
stuff with Karin Johnson then when
Nathan Myhrvold came in and he hired
Rick ration we got very serious about it
and it's been a phenomenal asset both I
hopefully to the field the people here
couldn't judge that but certainly for
Microsoft is we've tackled as we tackled
search with being as we have gotten into
a eyes we're infusing a eye into our
office productivity work more and more
the distance between okay here's what I
am SR is doing and here's the product
group is doing and it's gotten smaller
and smaller and even that boundary is a
little unclear it was never there was
always a very close collaboration and
being but and and I'd say in databases
that was pretty good in office it's more
a new thing where you have office online
and so you know take PowerPoint as an
example the ability to make suggestions
people and have them try them out and
within a few weeks see okay that people
are finding that useful let's do more of
it it's been fantastic to see and you
know so Microsoft Research has been just
an incredible investment even as we've
gone and scaled it up and done various
sites around the world every one of
those sites is managed to come in
a incredible level of excellence so so
we here at the at the 20th faculty
summit put on by Microsoft Research I
remember the first one it seems like
yesterday this one's on the future of
work
what are your some of your thoughts on
where jobs work productivity is going
and maybe even the role of computing
platforms and apps moving forward I
remember one great fear I had when we
did Microsoft research was that the if
we weren't careful would be a block to
our view of what was going on in the
academic community that is we would hire
somebody who had an approach and that
academia as a whole would have like 20
approaches you know number of which
would likely be better than some
internal approach and so I wanted
somebody who's open mind up to say no
the you know this group here is doing it
the right way and I was worried would
that fluidity exist so a lot of these
programs like having students come here
like the faculty summit have contributed
to the idea that ok we're part of a
broader committee community we publish
great things you know people come and go
a lot so I feel super good about that in
terms of work you know I would say the
most of the opportunity to make
computers improve work is in front of us
instead of behind us only it kind of a
very mechanical level of it's better
than whiteout you know are we like oh
wow this thing helps me get my work done
for extremely structured tasks like
creating financial statements you know
where the application logic is very
opaque and you're just led through it or
for very horizontal things where you
really understand what you're up to and
the Machine doesn't see oh that emails
part of personnel review that emails
part of planning the the Salesforce
meeting so we have kind of the low level
horizontal which in this ways amazing
and then we have this very structured
applications world the idea of matching
what you and your head have is the
attention of the overall act
and the semantics around it and
therefore sort of maximally helping you
with those things I think now that a lot
of base level things are are done very
well including gathering the data and
learning from it that we should be able
to have what the Machine thinks you're
up to and what you think you're up to
match each other and improve the
productivity quality quality quite
dramatically but it's a-me it's taken a
long time to get to this this point I'm
sort of chuckling because I've been at a
number of reviews and particularly
product teams at times where you share
your vision that's a great way of saying
it you should share your vision about
what you'd like to see in terms of the
deep understanding and knowledge these
systems have about people and their
tasks and I know that I've listened and
I always think wow this is like a grand
AI challenge we just can't do this
tomorrow so if I want to share a little
bit more about some of this the pursuit
that you've mentioned to me in front of
others but the you know of an ontology
of tasks and so on and well when you
write an email it it's not just some
random sweet generous thing that you
think hey I'd like to write an email let
me pick a random person and say some
random things you know generally you are
thinking about your kids college
application you're thinking about the
design of a product that you're engaging
on people with and so if you say to
somebody hey what are you doing
does that email relate to any others
does it relate any documents and he
lists any events very clearly there will
be a a somewhat of a hierarchy but to
say a graph of representations of a
heterogeneous set of things that you're
working on and you'll have a notion okay
if I don't get a response I'd like to
pay attention to that at some point in
the future and you know if I do get a
response in what context is it worth
bothering me with that you know if I'm
home on the weekend and somebody
responds to this do I
need to see that in my list or should I
should have just show up in context for
those things so there is a high level
intention and a taxonomy that the
machine and the human should be on the
same basis my you know executive
assistant does a better job of looking
at email in deciding which one is
important you know our taking of set of
phone calls and deciding which one she's
been the problem yeah yes so she can
take kept Virginia's data sources and
actually you know decide what things are
worth worth serving up but you know now
here we are thinking about how people
spend time and what those activities are
and not just having it be the super
rigid things you know what we see with
application software is often that like
if if you send something to a customer
and it's defective the software can't
capture the richness of that
conversation so you go into email or
text and say oh I'm so sorry but could
you take half of that we can send the
other half and you have all this
unstructured but very freeform dialogue
and then maybe that gets reflected back
into the system of record which is
overly structured the idea that that
something like you know personnel review
you could actually describe it in a
digital form without you know say
writing low-level code and you know just
saying having to say go to C++ write
logic it seems that that's a tractable
problem now all these things you've got
to make sure the work that the person
does pays off that they don't want to
spend a ton of time structuring some
simple thing that yes I'm asking my
friend to lunch and yes I expect him to
answer in 20 minutes I mean that would
be worth the trouble and so with a lot
of the automatic observation and machine
learning the idea of suggesting to
people hey this like looks like work NAM
work this looks like health seems like
you have these friends
hobbies the ability to structure those
things and you know make that part of
the UI and learn what types of tasks are
out there and you know how people think
oh this is similar to this one anyway I
think five years from now we will think
of the semantics of work as being more
modeled software understood than we do
today and we'll look back hopefully at
the way we're doing it now as far more
primitive and and you've been I know
privy to for your review the reviews we
do and the and the advising that you can
continue to do it Microsoft to a number
of late-breaking technologies and work
at product teams at Microsoft as well as
some of the the the offerings we've had
out there and though in the world and
what comes to mind as there's some
things that are exciting for you right
now from Microsoft well the whole you
know software as-a-service thing and the
ability to take the all the information
of the company and create a natural
language ability to navigate through you
know the history of the org chart the
history of the project dates the sales
data you know the idea that you
shouldn't have to really understand that
it's in this database in this column you
should be able to find patterns and the
Machine may suggest some patterns that
are interesting to you that is a you
know I'm in a long time ago 1991 I gave
a speech called information your
fingertips and we sort of have it in a
low-level sense that it's all online and
if you can write sequel statements you
know which database and you have the
right permission you know it's there
well now some of its in other forms of
database so maybe you need to know three
or four query languages but you know how
far away are we from letting you utter a
what any information worker might
typically want to ask about finding an
expert or the history of an account
or the sales in this region versus the
sales in that region and engage in an in
a dialogue on that I think we are
extremely close to being able to do that
and you know that's that's pretty
fantastic it's you know kind of nice to
see some of the original dreams come
true you know there is a dream about
really understanding text in a deep
sense that I have no idea how quickly
we'll get to that but I do think in the
next five years the semantics of tasks
and natural language navigation all all
of over all of the companies information
in a rich way and having an agent
participate in the meeting that kind of
listens and even kind of passively can
put things up on the screen that might
be of relevance or it can be told
explicitly to go get something and bring
that into the conversation it's keeping
the transcript I mean that kind of demo
that you know it's been done for decades
that thing will be real I'm people
actually want to use it and the amount
you'll have to charge them is so little
that it it might almost be the default
way of doing things if we call that info
agent and like the early 2000s and that
wasn't dream that we were pursuing and
back then of course there are many
there's a range of jobs and roles and
types of work and I thought folks would
find this in this video interesting of
your visit I guess when you're hanging
out with Warren Buffett in his home town
to to Dairy Queen I didn't really
realize he had a stake in dairy queen
okay so very broad minded person right
so we thought we'd roll this video of
your visit to to Dairy Queen
[Music]
here we are ready to go I need work this
is just a sample of our confidence if
you think this is bad wait we really get
into action
yeah just fill it up whoa whoa whoa keep
it going you got to get two balls on
this I'll see if I can do better
[Music]
oh my god yeah I'm very Duggars are
gonna order beautiful now I got to be
had the bad luck to draw me if you wanna
thing later on it's on me
the cone is okay
you guys want to learn how to help
customers move back a bit Milla called
is that all you wanted not to do it
that'll be what's up seller you didn't
do anything wrong it's just taking some
time so that barks at us you want a dip
or not tip that is really one of our
best pilots act if you don't eat it we
will yeah all right without looking it
simple and go banana split please okay
you're a real man all right what would
you like
I want a Oreo blizzards oh that's that's
one of our most popular how about what
else can we do
I want a medium Reese's
okay it's very popular is it absolutely
I like that peanut butter extra peanut
butter form yeah okay so the three most
important things about training somebody
new remember one's definitely patients
up with the handout from the money and
bilk under the net I just high-tech
stumped he's still gotta ask her what
she wants her dipping sauce
oh you dip chicken - Wow you're gonna
dip a lotta stuff around here number two
make sure you smile so they should smile
you know kind of pass the smiles along
we got it three have a good time and
treat a customer like there's somebody
that's in your own home whoa you get two
free ones for that
oh how to build Warren do today could've
done better
bill was good on the menu board Warren
was gonna take him credit so but all
around it alright I'd hire hi welcome to
Derry great can I take your order
I'll have a small Oreo blizzard that
will be $3 to 20 degrees - can you pull
forwards is an excellent Hill okay wow
that is for you do not up on this one
love to have you here thank you see you
[Music]
so it's really fun seeing the video of
you and Warren spending time some time
experiencing jobs and tasks in the fast
food industry we need to think about
special solutions for different kinds of
workers including blue-collar skilled
unskilled all the way up to company
executives or should we be thinking
broadly about platforms that work across
a spectrum of jobs yeah I mean they they
have this that way you put the ice cream
in a cone that they're very picky about
it swirling and not drop it out and then
they do that thing where it's upside
down you know just to show that you've
got really great ice cream that it's not
like all water or something anyway it
didn't work for a night if they'd given
us a hololens maybe you know we could
have been guided slightly better
yesterday when we were doing our
maternal mortality thing they had a they
gave me a hololens and i got to do
delivery on a my model we actually saw
how to get the baby's shoulder to come
through anyway it was quite impressive
and something that will actually be
deployed so for these physical tasks
there are special tools like augmented
reality that I think will help a lot you
know my personal desire is more for desk
work because that's 98 percent of what I
do is just shuffling the digital
equivalent of paperwork all the time but
you know certainly through my foundation
work when I think about farmers or
people out in primary health care you
know whether you're gonna live and die
with that meaning a doctor the idea that
remote assistance on complex tasks that
is something I'd like to see see us be
able to help raise the quality bar you
know speaking that I had a chance to
play with the whole lens - with Jamie
chaton and team at MSR Cambridge last
week I was I was blown away by how the
experience with the Hollins - and I know
we're already doing field tests and I
use cases with people using the mixed
reality in a number of job settings so
it's that's very promising I think in
some ways that the technology do you see
that really expanding it's a more
general usage yeah it's a passing
they've got a really strong roadmap and
it's nice that we're able to bootstrap
the volume with tasks you know like
inspecting an airplane engine that's
very high value you know some people
thought that okay the initial
incarnation will be a child walking
around their room and seen little
fairies flying around which of course
that's very important but we couldn't
quite hit the price point for that with
our first generation that tiny little
field of view it doesn't work you always
have to look for that little fairy
everywhere so it's like you know
Generation n that we'll get to that
original consumer version and we'll have
quite a variety of the things but in the
meantime the idea of the interaction I
mean one of the paradigm attic
applications is would you rather be in a
meeting which is a sort of Skype camera
representation with you know rectangles
for each of the source locations or
eventually can you have let's say pure
VR type medium where your avatar in
terms of your expression you know
laughing and a green who are you looking
at who are you talking to do we make
that in terms of the latency emotional
sharing you know richness competitive
and we're not you know we're not even
close the demos you know are getting
better and better and hololens is a a
piece of that but i still and sometimes
i'm over optimistic on these things I'd
put that the idea of that type of ad hoc
meeting in virtual space that we can see
your reaction and who you're talking to
and get the audio and video right on
that I think that should be within a
five-year time frame and and and once
you get it to be equivalent there's a
lot of things about it that are vastly
superior in that you're it you're not
partition
into these Oh three people that location
one at that location you really it is
much more free-flowing you know and then
eventually get the point of thinking
okay will that actually compete with
traveling to do activities in some cases
so they have a lower carbon footprint so
speaking of this idea of distribution
and and free-flowing we're seeing the
rise of gig economy freelance work apps
like uber that are having big effects in
the world and including effects on labor
and how work works any thoughts on what
this might mean moving into the future
and freelance economy
well the key element is education and it
is interesting in a certain way how now
that we have all you know courses about
almost everything you still have to pay
a little bit for the learning company to
get the very best but in math and
science even the free stuff is extremely
good that's out there and yet you know
and for early level math we have Khan
Academy and lots of things that has had
a truly modest effect on actual skill
levels and so the motivational aspects
you know why do you learn many people
learn just to get a degree because that
is how you get a job but how do you make
things interesting that's kind of an
unsolved problem so I do view you know
retraining and education that in order
to deal with the dynamism of this
fast-paced innovation that you also want
to make equivalent breakthroughs not
just in automating things but improving
education and if you could have one wish
to improve one thing in an economy you
know education is kind of the master
switch of your capability there's a few
things like energy and stability and
Trust that are important to but
education would be right up there and
yet you know if I say to you oh the best
math teacher lived fifty years ago he
was better than any math teacher since
then
you couldn't disprove that that was
right that is our understanding of how
you draw kids in and how you understand
their misconceptions is it's it's very
ad hoc the average math teacher today is
probably about the same as twenty years
ago and yet you know if we can do agents
you know we're talking about the general
issue of being able to read in inform
knowledge the idea being as good as
one-on-one math tutor and seeing what
types of conceptual mistakes people make
end even more importantly understanding
how you motivate them to you know that
you keep it at the right level or you
create the right sort of problem domain
that they might be interested in or you
know some sort of contest or draw a
social aspect into it that motivational
piece is where you see most of the
variance it's not domain knowledge that
you know makes difference as we see
because that it's online and yet we
don't see much change so I am enthused
about that whether that means that your
learning will be more episodic and you
continue do it an adulthood
you know that would be ideal so that
even if the job market is switching
you're qualified do you have a sense
that that will be needed in the future
more than it is today
somewhat I mean as society gets more
productive you're you know production
frontier moves out and so you can choose
to say okay we still have shortages we
you know or not at the production
frontier where you know every
handicapped kid has a full-time aide and
every older person has somebody visiting
them and helping them and but any of you
look at poor countries where people live
and die without ever meeting a doctor
and they're still malnutrition of forty
percent of the kids you know someday
Society will get to the point where our
sense of purpose won't be based on work
and avoiding disease and getting enough
food and we'll have to
have you know sort of a religious
philosophy philosophical view that you
know binds us together and has us
collaborate towards goals other than the
human basics in many cases we you know
aren't meeting what we'd all define as
those human basic so yes some degree of
retraining will be very important if
skills like driving become less in
demand or certain manufacturing type
activities become less in demand you
still have value and in society even
beyond the economics of it giving people
a sense of purpose something that
they're connected to is a very organized
helps organize society in particularly
you don't want large numbers of young
men who have nothing that they feel
engaged in a sense of a purpose and so
yes I do think that there's there should
be an equal amount of innovation and
discussion about helping people learn
new things motivating them if you could
supercharge education then you buy many
generations where the labor market is
well matched to what those demands will
look like so on this topic of the
evolution of tasks and jobs sets of
tasks there's been a lot of chatter
about the rise of new forms of
automation coming with reaching what is
largely perceived as an inflection point
in AI machine learning centric AI these
days with more automation coming on
there on the front frontiers of a edging
into into tasks of various kinds that
have required human intellect in the
past and so what's what's the short and
longer-term features of the influence of
AI innovations on jobs tasks in the
economy well some some things you know
we're always just gaining more respect
for
the human capacity to do the thing you
know speech recognition you know in the
60s people thought oh we must be close
that must be an easy thing
well now hey actually we are pretty good
but that's 50 years you know image
recognition you know we are the software
is really amazing
some things like the dexterity of the
human hand were not that good
the mobility piece is a closer to being
a solved problem but if you do combine
you know really incredible vision really
good arms really good legs and so the
tasks like cleaning up a room or
assembling something if those can be
done by robots eventually those robots
will not be super expensive they won't
make a lot of mistakes they won't take a
lot of breaks and so that you know and
it's hard to say what the date for that
is you know some people work in robotics
have told us that we're stupid to think
it's anytime soon
and then other people tell us oh it's
all exponential so just go to bed
tonight and wake up and the singularity
will be somewhere so you know there's
quite a range and I'm you know i say
more optimistic than Brooks and less
optimistic than than others but you know
society will want to be ready for the
point where those things happen we've a
little bit made it opaque by taking car
driving as the paradigm addict asked and
it has so much demand for reliability in
dealing with arbitrary situations that
are unexpected like somebody stopped in
front of you or the ball rolling out you
know shedding that momentum there's just
no magic way to do it and and so it may
actually hide from people that slowly
but surely dexterity cost of robots we
really are making progress on these
things I mean when Amazon said they were
gonna retrain a hundred thousand people
did what did that mean I wasn't sure but
that was nice of them to say that and
and so you know sometime I
do think in the next 20 years a lot of
things that are physical in nature even
with the complex recognition and you
know cleaning up a room is super hard
you have to have almost human-like
vision and arms to do it but so will
that be achievable in 20 years it'd be
interesting to get people to forecast
various things and see how much parents
there is so yes society should get ready
for that government policies in terms of
the education offerings the the way the
safety net works the way the tax system
work which currently discourages labor
you know you want to have a huge shift
since you have this you really want
labor so things that are more
encouraging of labor like your income
tax credit will dominate and things like
Social Security taxes that are cost you
on labor those will go away altogether
but you know we have many decades to get
this right but it is fairly dramatic
thing that you want to get society
broadly involved in helping you think
about with plenty of lead time so we
often think about hear the phrase future
of work I think most people at least in
this room think about the Western
developed world and then don't think
deeply about the large swath of humanity
that's outside the more developed
nations and the influence of technology
potentially including aii ot different
kinds of systems work going on and
platform work I thought we just show a
video of your visit to to a farm a
little bit east of here on the farm
beach project under run vir chandra at
MSR we'll roll that video and we'll come
back to some to discuss it more than
three-quarters of the poor people in the
world are farmers
they're faced with a very tough problem
they have to grow enough food to feed
their family every year when you think
of digital technology you don't think of
measuring soil moisture you don't think
about helping people know when to plant
or understand what's going wrong on the
farm but if we can make these sensors
small enough cheap enough then the
chance to get this down to more and more
farmers get them additional productivity
it's pretty exciting we take this data
we build machine learning anytime audits
to do two things one is virtual sensor
prediction so we're predicting things
like leap fairness evapotranspiration
and solar radiation we use the data to
customize the model for the farm and we
are getting very accurate results for
each of those the sensors use a new type
of connectivity that's very inexpensive
called TV white spaces TV white space is
unused bandwidth in between the TV
broadcast panels governments are now
allowing this bandwidth to be used to
transmit data in this case it's the
dated coming from the field that goes
back to the computers that helps create
the best advice to the farmer what
you're seeing here is a TV white spaces
rounder this is like your white my
antenna at home pouting all of this
through solar panels it is powered this
on and you get white by one demand in
we use it to send Germany machine once
the flight is complete it is not
transmitting the data or the white
spacer to do a position map generation
whoa Kevin leaves any data you can get
to farmers can make a huge difference
the weather is always highly variable
deciding should they invest in
fertilizer when did they plant
understanding which brought would be the
right one at this time even 20% more
productivity means that they can afford
school fees save a little bit for a
tough year and of climate change is
gonna make the farmer job a lot harder
and just closing that yield gap even a
modest amount would make a huge
difference for all those farmers so so
there's a suggestion that we could do a
lot we the broad community of folks
interested in technology in society
and applying advances in computing to to
assist and transform the nature of of
jobs and tasks and needs particularly
the developing world we actually know
one frontier does work in that Eastern
Washington farms but does most of his
work out in Indian Africa these days
looking at parallels and trying to
generalize it thoughts about technology
in adult and what firms in the future of
work well certainly there are areas
particularly Africa where you know the
population growth will be very high you
know the world at large the birth cohort
has peaked and so actually all the aid
all the global level population increase
is people surviving longer so that
filling out the age pyramid but that
masks a very dramatic shift where over
the course this century have to choke
the number of children born will go down
in the non Africa parts will go down
quite a bit and they number in Africa
will go up quite a bit and so you know
Africa is projected to
to sub-saharan Africa - triple -
quadruple their population and they
already have very small farms with very
low productivity and they have climate
change and the quality of the governance
in terms of getting farmers advice and
infrastructure is actually pretty
limited and so anything you can do
whether it's better seeds you know
getting through their mobile phone
advice to them helping them if they have
three good years be able to get a good
price so that you know say they go from
one and every ten years is bad one every
four years they can use their monetary
savings to get through that without
basically having extreme malnourished
month that if they didn't have the
savings that's what they'd have to go
through so there's many ways that we
want to attack this this problem there
was a thing called digital green
actually out of the IBM Microsoft
research stuff that is being used to
give some of those farmers advice it
that helps but we have such a long ways
to go even at the seed level things like
photos photosynthetic efficiency you
know and that's very advanced work to
try and get more into their fields and
sort of recreate what happened with the
Green Revolution but I'd say whether or
not enough can be done to avoid the
living conditions that are being even
worse than they are today it really does
hang in the balance
so changing topics a bit it seems at
least for me my family friends and
colleagues that work and family time
work and recreation play start
interleaving a bit I seem to be working
all the time
my wife comments on this and it seems
that that technology has been in part
the source for some of that interleaving
maybe some of it's a good thing we have
talked about about about that maybe it's
a personal comments for you in life well
everybody has to have a certain sense of
discipline you can't
read all the books you want to read and
so time allocation it's it's you know
maybe particularly my situation you know
the what the most limited resource there
is and so deciding okay you know family
activities and taking you know some time
off and then still getting the great
enjoyment out of the time I spend on
Microsoft work and and also the
foundation work you know I I I analyze
how am i spend my time pretty carefully
you know and then I like the fact that
when I'm on vacation I can read books
about the latest in AI or biology you
know that's when I get to read super
complicated things and in some cases
actually write write fairly good memos
you know my I go back and look at my
time and and see you know I'm super
lucky experts are often willing to come
talk to me about things you know so
yesterday we're talking about birthing
we have you know people who've spent
their whole life trying to improve
maternal survival and just you know
phenomenal to hear about how the new
technology and their experience can come
together on those things and my kids are
now the last one is in high school so
actually we're you know worried that we
won't have the distractions of having
kids around because that's you know a
big pleasure to do that thing my wife
and I because we were together at the
foundation we don't have any shortage of
time together which is cool right it's
fantastic some people some people when
their kids leave it's like wow that was
our our main joint project so what do we
do together now but I you know I take
advantage of the tools you know I look
at my or a ring and see if I've had
enough REM sleep and sometimes I worry
you know why should do am i spending too
much time thinking about things like
that but you know you calibrate after a
while how much the tools really helpful
or not
so you mentioned how important
engagement is as when come mental and
I'll end with this is I and I think
they're people in this room and the rest
of the world are so amazed and happy
about how engaging been with everything
the new things you learn Microsoft the
foundation so I'll give you a big thank
you thank you very all right thanks Eric
very much
[Applause]